but this is this is why this is why
earlier i bought in history and the fact
that
there was a point where women we weren't
even allowed in education so in terms of
financially men have already had their
head start
that's why i would say that okay women
they tend to be homeless because men
have had the head start from
that's why i'm saying our generation is
going to change things a lot because in
terms of women are going to be able to
catch up a lot more
so women are going to be able to catch
up a lot more um yeah i feel like we
can't ignore history when it comes to
finding when you're considering
financial the financial position of men
and women you can't ignore history i
just get totally sick of that
you know when it comes to like the
finances because i've worked in jobs
and i've earned the same as the men
and when they talk about all this pay
gap and that the men have had it and the
women have had it as far as i'm
concerned there's no reason why a woman
can't go out there and get paid the same
money for
the same qualifier same qualified same
qualifications same job same experience
i've done it
i've done it and i've also got a pay
rise every year i've never ever worked i
had a man on the same
role as me
same experience earn more than me so
when they and you're talking about the
old generation i'm the old generation
but what i'm trying to say is this
what sector is this transport management
in transport okay and it doesn't matter
where it is because wherever you go you
can get paid are these sectors you're
required to have a certain level of
qualification any job you can go any job
that a man can get qualified and get
paid a woman who is equally qualified
equally experienced and has the same
manner when it comes to working because
that's what we let women down
their mannerisms when they go in they
even go in like oh you know they're
going too strong but if you go in the
job with the right frame of mind and
nowadays the women are more qualified
from in my generation that's what you're
going to say the women are more
qualified in the old generation we
weren't that qualified and the young
generation they were qualified now so
there is no reason for people to say oh
but the men have got it now because
they've earned more that's rubbish
nowadays well especially for the new
generation because it's there for you on
the plate you've got it better than us
yeah so i don't understand like what
does that have to do with me today that
like some women were locked out of
education before i was born how does
that affect me because even in these
environments let's say
a woman has managed to get to let's say
a very senior position it's still an
environment that is dominated by male
nurse
especially whites smellness so for
instance if you're a white woman and
you've now come into this space you have
to overcome the barrier of being a woman
in a
a male-dominated space no i don't
okay so how would you how would you
you work hard like that's what i see
like every time someone blames their pay
on the pay gap they're lazy honestly
they're lazy because the pay gap doesn't
exist when you take in this is what you
don't understand when you take into
account personality differences between
men and women women don't ask for raises
that's the problem 60 of women have
never asked for a raise and you're going
to complain that you don't get paid the
same you don't ask for a raise that's
what i'm saying the environment a man
because this is an environment that men
have been in no it's a
choice before women if i personally me
personally i would ask for a raise but
it's it's different because the it takes
confidence to ask for that confidence in
yourself and if you're in an environment
that wasn't even made for people like
you people like you
for some women there will be some of the
there will be some of the first people
in that kind of environment and they
have to thrive in that you have to
overcome the barrier of having to adapt
in that environment that's something a
man doesn't have to
when there are quotas okay so there are
specific quotas to give women jobs over
men
men don't have any quotas so we're given
they don't need it no
no because
why why do they why do we need a quota
do you not think women are qualified to
get the job on their own i didn't say
that no but that's what you're implying
by saying
no no no no that's why i said you can't
ignore the history no because the reason
the quote is that's an excuse
that's an excuse i'm not saying it's an
excuse
anyone can go out and get any job they
want nothing's stopping us there's no
law stopping us and if anything there's
incentives i've i mean i've worked in a
male
dominated environment all my life
and i can't honestly say i was the only
black woman supervisor black woman
manager
props and it never props to me it was a
job i didn't care whether i was black or
not i'm getting the money i'm getting
the same one as everybody else to me it
didn't matter if i was black or not it
was a job
and the men have got the job i've got
the job they're earning the same as me
and every year i make sure i got my pay
rise the way they did
and you didn't and i had the same
attitude you didn't make it no and the
thing is and the thing is with women i
find that when they go out like yes your
attitude has to change i'm in a male
environment i'm overloaded male so yeah
you know i mean i can hold my own i can
have a conversation i'm gonna dress
feminine but i'm gonna stand my own like
masculine but you see when i step out
the house and i get onto my man
all feminine
submissive
and that's what the women feel to
realize that the new generation because
you can go out there and you can do a
job just as good as a man and when you
come home you forget that you're a woman
you still go on like you're a man that's
what the men don't like
i'm i didn't i did everything everything
could insinuate it i did it
i'm not insinuating i'm just saying i'm
speaking from experience because i don't
want to hear the excuse of oh because
you're a woman you've got to go in that
environment and that's a certain way
rubbish because of your color rubbish
because of your sex rubbish because of
the pay rubbish because i've done it
and it's the norm i've done it so all
women need to do if you want to get paid
more the same way how you can speak up
and say i'm a woman this and that
speaker must say excuse me but i'm do
you pay your eyes can i have my money
this is how hard i've worked this is
what i deserve and this is what my
contract says now that's what i'm saying
that now you can do that but it hasn't
always been like that no i'm older than
you i'm 53 i'm retired so you can't say
now you can do that because i've been
doing it okay but you can't this is what
i mean you can't ignore the history okay
but before you i'm history i'm
i'm the history
i am the history i am
ignoring history i am 53 i am retired i
am your history so you can't tell me to
forget about the history
history and before my history my mother
done the same job as a black woman i
don't remember the same joke i don't
want to offend you but you can't afford
them it's not like that in every sector
it's not it's not like that if you're
talking about research if you're talking
about the top sectors because they're
still for instance in if you're talking
about science if you're talking about
tech if it's all about engineering these
sectors there's still a lack of women
why because the women go and do it if
there's a lack of women go and do it i
wanted to be a bus driver there was lack
of women you know i done i didn't
complain and said there's no room in bus
drivers go and do it they didn't have no
managers go and do it don't sit back
complaining that in these top sectors
nowadays you've got all the
qualifications you the young people you
can go university you can get degrees go
and do it you know i mean women are if
you want to do something don't complain
about it change it like like you said
women are doing it but the results are
still not the same not really they're
not doing
them women are the most educated but
they don't make more money because they
have a ton of debt and women don't make
the majority of workplace deaths where's
the equality where are the marches men
are the majority of workplace deaths
they do all of the hard jobs therefore
they get more money do you want to be a
plumber do you want to be a bricklayer
the only the only jobs you're seeing are
the the two percent of jobs like ceos
power power positions hypothetically but
my dad was one of those top one percent
ceos he worked 80 hours a week for 40
years do you want to do that i don't
most women don't they want to have kids
okay that's again that's why i said this
is you can't
you can't mix the two because you're
saying women should focus
with what you're saying you're saying
women should focus on having kids and
for that reason they wouldn't be able to
do that 80 hours a week
no i'm not i'm not saying what women
should and shouldn't do i'm saying i
don't like excuses i'm not making i'm
not no because you are you're blaming
you're blaming the pay gap on being a
woman i'm not blaming them
you're saying we need to be aware
you're saying we need to be aware of our
history i'm saying that has nothing to
do with me today i was born in 2022.
there is nothing that is holding me back
as a woman if anything it's offered me
advantages because all the men hiring
are attracted to you
no i that's
you you apply for a job you're a pretty
young girl most men that hire you are
going to be attracted to you to be young
again yes i'll do it all again youth
women
do not believe that oh to be young again
no no
it's true it's true and the thing is
you you was talking about history and
that men had a head start it's been that
way since the dawn of time and it's only
recent that we've come into this
this time and and that the outcomes are
terrible this is the first time we're
changing it you know i'm a boss lady i'm
making money i'm getting the bag and
look fifty percent of women are by their
self
one in four women are on antidepressants
and on top of that how can we say we
were disadvantaged before when we didn't
have to fight in wars
the men were the ones that had to go
find words we'll save my body my choice
all day but we'll never talk about their
body their choice when they get drafted
women the majority of women didn't even
want the right to vote because it came
with the responsibility of getting
drafted so most girls are like i'm a
chill in the kitchen and i absolutely
would chill in the kitchen if that was
the same thing today that's the mindset
that that's the mindset that she had
again i wouldn't say that the mindset
that i have is the mindset of the
majority
but again like i said you can't use that
to you can't use that to just dismiss
what has happened like he said he said
men he said that men have had their head
start and it's been like that since the
dawn of time but now that times are
changing
you guys are still you are still placing
the value of women on fertility and in
the sexual marketplace i did not say
personal value i said in the sexual
marketplace
okay so the men the fact you mentioned
that a man had to do 80 hours a week why
can't a woman do that then that's what
i'm asking a woman can they choose not
to
i'm telling you like i i watched my dad
work his whole life i didn't know my dad
really until i was older i barely saw
him and
i i most women would not sign up for
that they can't keep lawyers at high-end
law firms past like the age of 35
because they say screw this i have all
the money i want all i want now is a
family
they can't pay these women to stay
because after a certain age your looks
are starting to go
you're what are you doing this for after
you make a certain amount of money so
again the thing that's limiting women is
what they're faced with what you just
said they're personal choices and i
don't think it's limiting women
i don't so if there's nothing stopping
us from doing anything today and more
women say hey i would rather stay home
or take a lower paying job that i like
instead of doing the shitty job that all
the men are doing why is that a bad
thing
you can't say personal choice because a
man doesn't have to make that choice yes
he does that's my point a man can make a
choice of do i want to go into education
which pays less or do i want to be a
plumber that pays more you mentioned at
35 women go off and that's when they go
and start their family a man could have
had a family up until that point he
doesn't have to make that choice that's
what i'm saying no he can he can be a
stay-at-home dad if he wants to but you
can't get rid of her biological roots he
can also make that choice he could go
get a sugar mama
i mean certain men not everyone has that
not all guys can pull that off but but
you see what i'm saying he could he
could do a 50 50 relationship there's
nothing stopping us from making these
choices it's just women don't want to
work hard jobs
men do i just think women have got more
choices now and they're just using
excuses they've got more choices than
ever they're more powerful than ever
they've got more rights more everything
than what i had in the past but what are
the outcomes
they're more unhappier than ever right
one in four women are on antidepressants
women own two thirds of the debt
even though they make less money 70 to
80 percent of consumer decisions are
made by women when married women are
more likely to be divorced three years
after their promotion to ceo levels
compared to their male counterparts
and they divorce men 70 to 80 percent of
the time
again like i said i don't think the
mindset that i have is the mindset of
the majority of women
but again you can't dismiss the things
that are
the things that are um
limiting women from getting to that
point you can't dismiss it
what is limiting us in 2022
if i've gone and i've had a child if i
was
okay let's say for instance i was in the
middle of my degree
and i've had a child
i i'm not in the same position as a man
at all did you just wait to have the
child
okay what about the states so i
abortionately is not illegal okay that's
incorrect
it's not illegal in the u.s
no i said what about the states the
states
states in general i'm not talking about
the united states i'm talking about
states in general no i'm saying you're
i'm saying in the united states abortion
is not illegal you get a car and drive
to another state that has i'm not
talking about the united states i'm
talking about states in general i'm
talking about the world in general i
feel like a lot of what we're saying and
a lot of what we're
discussing is focusing on the developed
world
it's ignoring because we're in the west
that's what we're talking about the west
okay but i don't think we could we
should ignore the reality of so many
women but i'm saying you're moving the
goal post because we were discussing the
west and now you're saying well what
about what about the not the west but
we're talking okay sorry i'll talk about
women i'm talking about women
generically
generically because when you're bringing
when you're talking about the debt
you're talking about all of those things
that's women in the west and those are
choices they're making
so would you agree there's nothing
holding back women in the west there's
nothing oppressing us history doesn't
matter because we're all born today
nothing we're cool
nothing to complain about
i would say we're not as limited as
people in the developing world that's
what i would say